[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events if you'd like to
see us on the road head on over to
theminimalists.com to find a city near
you or you can watch recordings of all
of our live events over at patreon.com
the minimalists
enjoy do i see a question over here
howdy
step on up what's your name my name is
michelle briggs hey michelle
where are you from and how much money do
you make just kidding
that's a dave ramsey jokes
my boss is dave ramsey if you know so
yeah where are you from how much money
do you make first kiss was it weird go
got it so uh first and foremost i want
to acknowledge you gentlemen for who you
are for us in this world so thank you
for what you're doing thank you so much
um truly
michelle that is why we do it honestly
like if it was just you who said that
yeah i would be like
wow like
we're really affecting michelle's life
but that is that's why josh and i keep
doing this so thank you so much for that
no no worries um and that's why i'm here
tonight because i truly believe that is
who you are
so
for me i think i'm a closet minimalist
and uh it's kind of funny because i've
done the 30 you know the 30 day
challenge i've done those things i've
had the conversations and it's so much
more than just removing things
hence the conversation and the gentleman
that we have this evening
what do you do with those people i say
those excuse me the individuals in your
life that you want to share this with
where do you start them that doesn't
because i love the conversation of
discovering and having the moment that
you can look inside yourself and say who
am i being why am i acting this way can
i let's take a step back and see who am
i right now can i ask you a question
sure why do you feel compelled to to
convince them that minimalism is useful
it's not convincing it's sharing an
opportunity to live a different way okay
and a different mindset set not a
different mindset but a different point
of view what what compels you to do
um because i think there's a simplicity
behind it and it's the the it's the
emptying it's emptying the noise in your
brain
it's like just stop for a second and
quit
that is i don't know maybe trying to
support them and not being so anxious
and not being
so crazy and stressed it's like stop and
like where do you start that
conversation with them and not be a
therapist
can i
so one of the uh
one of the most common questions i get
this is joel's show but i'm taking i'm
just kidding
one most common questions i get from
parents no let me back up i'll tell you
this so i was doing a practicum so i
went back to grad school as an old
person and so i had to do an internship
again i was the dean of students of the
texas tech law school
back in school again and i had to do an
internship with a psychologist that was
like 10 or 15 years younger than me
and he was a savant and we were working
with extreme
you couldn't wrap your head around
abuse children okay and so we were going
through this this one summer was when i
was doing this and i also had a young
son and we were going from room to room
what i did would do is i would take this
case and try to wrap thinly veiled
questions about how to be a good parent
to this
incredible psychologist i was asking
parenting questions but i was using
these kids we were working on his
proxies
um i'm a real classy guy by the way so
we're going from room to room i'll never
forget this
and we were talking to a young kid he
had was teaching us how to cook
meth in his is he's maybe four he was so
that was just he was just teaching us
how to roll joel i mean it was this
whole thing
and he was saying some really negative
things about women
and as we were leaving i was asking a
question how do you teach a young boy
what do you say to a young kid to help
him respect women when he's older
and he he smiled at me
this day
he looked at me he said
you don't tell kids anything they don't
listen to you they watch you
if you want and he said he clowned me he
said if you want your son to respect
women treat your wife right and he just
walked into the next room
and so what i would tell you is
as a guy who goes to church
there's nothing no one has ever been
like you know what i should do i should
try the church thing out because i just
lost your argument that's never happened
ever
ever and so my i you guys do this a lot
i would tell you if you want to
teach people about the simplicity and
peace being able to go to bed with no
medication and get up with no chemicals
be able to
walk through life a little bit lighter
you live that and i promise people will
come to you like a moth to a flame and
say i want that what is that and then
you could be like oh these two guys are
so great and then you can get that right
you know what's interesting is that is
how i stumbled across minimalism so josh
i started noticing like how happy he was
how much freer he was i never forget
like
uh when we were in the corporate world
you know we're working 60 70 sometimes
80 hours a week and uh he told me this
story about how our boss called him and
it was like i don't know six o'clock on
christmas eve
and he kept calling and calling josh
telling me stories like he keeps calling
me and calling me calling me and finally
answer up and i'm like hey man can i
help you and he's like yeah i need to
know i need to know where your where
your numbers are at how are the how are
your retail stores doing right now and
he was like
hey man i don't i don't know
and he was like what do you mean you
don't know he's like you know you're the
regional manager blah blah blah
and and josh he just is like hey
i think what you're asking right now is
an unreasonable expectation
and oh by the way um
i'm not going to answer your calls past
6 p.m anymore and and i'll get to you
you know around eight more like he
started setting these boundaries and
that is when i noticed i'm like what the
hell is going on with josh
like something has changed in him and
that's when i sat him down and i asked
him i'm like dude why the hell are you
so happy and that's when he told me
about this thing called minimalism and
as i went through my process of
simplifying in the packing party has
anyone not heard of the packing party
story
okay awesome
so i don't have to spend 10 minutes
telling that story amazing so i went
through that packing party story and i
thought to myself i'm like oh wow like
there might be some people who find
value in this story who find value on
our story so that's when josh and i did
what any two 30 year old dudes would do
we started a
blog and uh what happens is that when
you add value to someone's life they
want to they want to share you know your
message your story with other people and
that is how josh and i have come the way
we are and that's where you're at right
now you're like you're finding value in
it and you want to share this message
with your friends and family and i
totally agree with what delony is saying
here is is yes live it and people will
come to you and you don't go to them and
say well hey you got it go ahead what's
up
like what i said i'm like a closet
minimalist
[Laughter]
i've got an opportunity for them i was i
if in another context i would have
thought you had like amway or tupperware
in your trunk right
do you have any sort of a way of being i
just all they want to know is like all
right tell me a podcast give me a few
numbers and i'm going to go look listen
get on there listen to these podcasts
and you know call me what you think so
but that that's actually a really good
recommendation for someone who is
stressed out
and there's some because i wouldn't go
to someone and be like oh you need to
check out though minimalists because
like i said in that talk earlier like
the word minimalism is so extreme to
some people that they just automatically
shy away from it so i would pick one of
the other isms and i would just i would
recommend to them something that has
added value to your life whether it's a
blog post that leo babalta wrote or
whether it's a podcast that that josh
and i wrote whatever it is like you can
share something or maybe it's you know
the minimalism documentary whatever it
is when you see someone stressed out and
they're maybe looking to you for an
answer then you can recommend you know
just a tiny little like
hey i watched this document i
i feel i used to feel how you feel right
now and i you know i checked out this
this one article and it really helped me
put things into a different perspective
it might help you put things into a
different perspective but for the love
of god don't call yourself without
minimalist because you find out real
quickly who your friends are i'll tell
you that
hey can i just say i just we just met
just like a minute ago thank you for
trying to put joy into the world we need
more of that what a great heart i'm
grateful for you thank you thank you
appreciate it
[Applause]
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free